you might have noticed something weird
about Donald Trump's lawyers what
politics is it's lawyers versus lawyers
so now you hope your team Republicans Or
democrats have the best lawyers so they
can go after the other guy but it feels
like the Republicans don't never feels
like they have the best lawyers it never
feels like they have the best lawyers
yes Greg it's so weird why can't Donald
Trump and the Republicans hire good
lawyers it must be because they can't
afford those great corporate lawyers who
everyone knows are known for being
Democrats now with all his criminal
entanglements as well as his habit of
filing a mountain of civil lawsuits
Donald Trump employs an army of lawyers
and in fact his save America political
action committee spent more than 21
million dollars this year on lawyers for
Trump and his associates and boy is he
mad about getting the Trump campaign to
spend vast amounts of money on legal
fees thereby having less to spend on ads
showing that crooked Joe is the worst
president in United States history yeah
but the problem for Trump is he is quite
possibly the world's worst client and so
the best lawyers in the country won't go
near him even before January 6 his
reputation for stiffing his counsel and
erratic Behavior drove away Powerhouse
conservative firms like Jones day and
Kirkland and Ellis plus there's his
habit of attacking judges prosecutors
Witnesses jurors civil servants and even
his own lawyers on social media but
after the attack on the capital Trump
became completely toxic to the point
that he often has to pay millions of
dollars up front to convince competent
lawyers to leave their law firms to
represent him which means that Trump is
facing down four serious criminal
indictments accompanied by a Motley Crew
of attorneys with um
varying qualifications so let's rank
them so we'll start with s tier
there are no s tier lawyers uh Donald
Trump doesn't hire or can't hire best
tier lawyers there just aren't any sorry
but that takes us to a tier Yes
somewhere near the top of the Trump
legal mountain or I guess legal Foothill
sits New York attorney Todd Blanche a
former Federal prosecutor in White
Collar criminal defense attorney in New
York Blanche left the law firm of
cadwallet or Wickersham and Taft in
April and that represents Trump in the
New York State case the Florida
documents case and the election
interference case in DC and if you're
looking for a cheat to decode Trump's
lawyers here it is the more time they
spend in TV studios running their mouths
the less serious they are about their
day jobs and Todd Blanche is never on
television and neither is Susan Nicholas
a highly respected criminal defense
lawyer in New York necklace represents
Trump in the New York prosecution as
well as the E Gene Carroll civil
defamation suits also a tier is Chris
Kai's Florida's former solicitor general
who is also pretty camera shy in August
of 2022 Trump's save America pack paid
kinds 3 million million dollars to leave
the nationally recognized firm of Foley
and Larder now at the time Trump was
trying to fend off the document's
investigation but after advising the
former president to Simply give back
everything he swiped and make a deal to
avoid prosecution kaiz was banished to
work on the New York civil case against
Trump and the Trump Organization for
submitting false Financial info to Banks
and insurance companies because what
better use of an expert in Florida law
who knows every judge in the Sunshine
State than to ship him off to New York
right but now Kai's is back on the
documents case since Trump couldn't find
anyone else who was both admitted to
practice law on the southern district of
Florida and willing to be associated
with the manga world and then rounding
out eight here we have Steve sat out a
criminal defense lawyer in Atlanta with
a lot of experience representing
celebrity clients and battling George's
expansive RICO law but on the eve of his
surrender to law enforcement Trump
swapped Sato in for self-proclaimed
billion dollar lawyer Drew feindling who
spent the last six months trying and
failing to head off the Georgia
indictment but now let's skip to B tier
and man it is all downhill from here
first up we have John lauro the Tampa
based attorney leading the defense in
Trump's DC Pro Fusion he spends a lot of
time on TV and managed to hit each of
the five Sunday talk shows on August 6
after the DC indictment dropped lauro
made a series of wild claims as he
hopped from camera to camera and he told
Chuck Todd that quote a technical
violation of the Constitution is not a
violation of criminal law he promised
George Stephanopoulos that Mike Pence
will be one of our best Witnesses at
trial and on CBS he vowed to ask the
court to move the trial out of DC to
West Virginia for diversity and here's
Dana bash's face when lauro described
the peaceful transition of power in
2021. there was a peaceful transition of
power so that's how the Constitutional
Works what happened on January 6th was
not peaceful and Laura was not just
making those crazy arguments to the
cameras in court he objected to a
protective order blocking Trump from
posting evidence from the case on Truth
social calling it a content-based
regulation on President Trump's
political speech and complaining that
quote in a trial about First Amendment
rights the government seeks to restrict
First Amendment rights then another beat
here Trump employer who loves the
spotlight is New York litigator Joseph
takapina after a jury awarded Eugene
Carroll five million dollars for sexual
assault and defamation takapina
congratulated himself and his client on
the courthouse steps because quote
Donald Trump was not granted a rapist
takovina is also part of the team
representing Trump in the New York
criminal case here he is explaining to
Ari melber that Trump simply had to lie
to the public about the payoff to Stormy
Daniels because she was extorting him
and they signed a confidentiality
agreement because it was a confidential
settlement so if he acknowledged that he
would be violating the confidential
settlement so is it the truth of course
it's not the truth was he supposed to
tell the truth he would be in violation
of the agreement if he told the truth
oddly enough takapina also claimed back
in 2018 to have an attorney-client
relationship with Daniels because she
consulted with him briefly about the
very same matter which is probably true
and is very worrying though a New York
judge recently decided that there is no
conflict based on takapina's
representations then moving down the
proverbial ladder to C tier we get to
Jim trustee and John Rowley who
represent Trump while he was being
investigated by special counsel Jack
Smith in both the documents case and the
January 6 investigation and they had
some success in the summer of 2022 when
judge Eileen Cannon temporarily put the
document's case on hold before being
humiliatingly reversed by the 11th
circuit but trustee and rally had no
such success in DC where former Chief
judge Beryl Howell blasted their
attempts to use executive privilege to
block former Trump Administration
officials from testifying to the grand
jury trustee also filed a 475 million
dollar lawsuit alleging that CNN defamed
the former president by using the phrase
the big lie Trump and trustee claimed to
be quote vindicating the first
amendment's Marketplace of ideas but the
case got tossed because calling someone
names is not defamation in May trustee
and rally sent a completely nutty letter
to attorney general Merrick Garland
demanding that he meet with them to
quote discuss the ongoing Injustice that
is being perpetrated by your special
counsel and his prosecutors no president
of the United States has ever in the
history of our country been baselessly
investigated in such an outrageous and
unlawful fashion and they got their
meeting at the justice department albeit
not with the AG but just days later the
special counsel indicted Trump in the
documents case a day later trustee and
rally quit calling it quote a logical
moment for us to step aside and let
others carry the cases through to their
completion they added that they had
quote no plans to hold media appearances
that address our withdrawals or any
other confidential Communications we've
had with the president or his legal team
now that was probably a backhanded
reference to Tim parlatore another CT
attorney who left Trump's legal team a
month before trustee and rally and on
his way out the door parlatory blamed
yet another Trump lawyer Boris Epstein
who is really just a close advisor of
Trump's parlatory told CNN's Paula Reed
that Epstein had quote who had really
done everything he could to try to block
us to prevent us from doing what we
could to to defend the president who's
not very honest with us or with the
client on certain things but more on
Boris in a minute he's
he's not in the sea tier but it is quite
unusual for an attorney to quit and then
share details of the client
representation on National Television or
you know at least it used to be also
nixed from the Trump legal team although
not by choice is Evan Corcoran known in
the documents indictment As Trump
attorney number one after Trump got a
grand jury subpoena Corcoran negotiated
with the justice department to turn over
all remaining classified documents at
Mar-A-Lago and according to prosecutors
Trump asked Corcoran uh quote what
happens if we just don't respond at all
or don't play ball with them end quote
wouldn't it be better if we just told
them we don't have anything here you
know just asking questions
after Corcoran told Trump that's really
not how subpoenas go they agreed that
the lawyer would fly to Florida and
search the pool shed where Trump was
storing boxes full of government
documents but of course before Corcoran
arrived Trump had his Florida
co-defendants Walt NADA and Carlos De
Oliveira to bring the boxes upstairs so
he could pull out what he wanted to keep
allegedly and before Corcoran arrived on
June 2nd 2022 now to Endeavor return the
boxes to the storage locker a Corcoran
searched the boxes and found 38
documents with classified markers which
he returned to the FBI on June 3rd along
with a certification promising that no
more remained on the property but while
Corcoran prepared that certification it
was actually attorney Christina Bob who
signed it which is why Corcoran is in
the seat here and Bob is a little bit
further down but of course that
certification was false as the FBI
discovered two months later when it
turned up with a warrant and discovered
more than 100 additional classified
documents on the premises some of them
containing sensitive military Secrets
but Trump's lies put Corcoran in a
position and where no lawyer wants to be
judge Howell ruled that Trump had lied
to his counsel enlisting him in a
criminal scheme and so the crime fraud
exception could be used to pierce the
attorney-client privilege Corcoran was
forced to testify to the grand jury and
hand over his notes including a lengthy
voice memo he dictated to himself
describing the entire episode this
formed the basis of several counts of
the documents indictment including
conspiracy to obstruct Justice
withholding a document or record
concealing a document in a federal
investigation and making false
statements it also turned Corcoran into
a witness against his own client after
which he was forced to withdraw the
representation now these lawyers are
terrible but if you need a good lawyer
my firm the eagle team can help if
you've had an injury or death in the
family suffer from a data breach or were
involved in a car crash or almost
anything else we can represent you or
help find you the right attorney who can
just click on the link in the
description for a free consultation with
my team because you don't just need a
legal team you need the eagle team the
link is below now back to Trump's
terrible attorneys and that leaves just
one more Trump lawyer earning a birth
into the coveted seat here Jesse Bunnell
came into Trump's orbit during the
election and he handles much of the
Appellate work where Trump has to make
bad arguments with a straight face in
2020 been all sued Nevada falsely
claiming that Trump won the state he
represented Trump in his effort to block
the national archives from releasing his
presidential records to the January 6
committee and he's currently
representing Trump in an appeal of a
doomed Rico lawsuit that he filed
against Hillary Clinton in Florida and
after prosecutors started pointing out
in their briefing that lauro seemed to
be spending all of his time on TV
talking about the case team Trump
dispatched banal in his stead to explain
to CNN how Mike Pence was going to be a
star witness for team Trump but if it
ever does make it to trial Mike Pence is
going to be a star witness for Donald
Trump okay and now we're just jumping
right into the legal Chasm that is f
tier or as a trump campaign Chief Jason
Miller referred to it the Star Wars bar
[Music]
uh at this point in the game it's
probably easiest to divide Trump's
lawyers into attorneys who haven't been
named as co-conspirators and those who
have in the second category New York
lawyer Elena Haba stands out for her
willingness to say literally anything in
defense of her client ahaba accused the
FBI of planting classified documents at
Mar-A-Lago she called Trump the okay he
was the most ethical American I know and
she threatened Mayhem if the doj dared
to indict her client Haba is responsible
for some of Trump's weirder lawsuits
including one against the New York Times
for publishing Trump's tax records that
one got tossed out without sanctions but
she wasn't as Lucky in the Civil Rico
suit against Hillary Clinton James Comey
and dozens of other Democrats and FBI
officials in that case a Florida federal
judge ordered Trump and Haba to cough up
almost a million dollars in attorney's
fees and castigated Haba for wasting the
Court's time quote this case should
never have been brought its inadequacy
as a legal claim was evident from the
start no reasonable lawyer would have
filed it Haba and her partner Michael
bedeo also represented Trump in the
Eugene Carroll case and the New York AG
civil prosecution and adding grists for
the mill Trump's lawyers Michael Dale
Clifford Robert Michael Farina Chris
kais and Armin morian were all fined and
sanctioned in the New York AG civil suit
against the Trump org in which the Trump
org has been ordered to be dissolved and
yes we are definitely working on a video
about that but recently Trump announced
that Haba would be withdrawing to take a
position with Trump's save America Pac
as his legal spokesperson and media
representative on legal matters in
essence she's getting paid by Trump's
donors to go on TV and defend him rather
than practice law which
um honestly is probably a much better
deal for everyone but she's not the only
one Christina Bob a former Jag lawyer
turned one American News host uh cut out
the middleman and came to work for Trump
after the election she's the one who
signed the false declaration saying that
there were no more classified documents
at Mar-A-Lago and is described as Trump
attorney number three uh in the
documents indictment she apparently
testified to the grand jury meaning that
she may well be a witness for the
prosecutor in that case nevertheless Bob
regularly takes to the airwaves to
confidently claim things like it's kind
of funny I think the folks in New York
president Trump and his family probably
had a better view than I did because
they had the CCTV that they were able to
watch I you know I was stuck in the
parking lot there to you know collect
paper and answer questions but they were
actually able to see the whole thing so
they they actually have a better idea of
what took place inside and that was over
a year ago and so far all we've gotten
is an indictment that alleges that Trump
ordered his henchmen to delete the
security camera footage but maybe we'll
get a peek at those tapes during
infrastructure week but while Bob
doesn't enter her appearances in court
on Trump's behalf attorney Lindsey
Halligan does the former minor Insurance
defense lawyer had never worked a single
federal case before coming into Trump's
orbit in 2022 and entering her
appearance in the Florida documents case
and the lawsuit against CNN she also
attended meetings at the justice
department with trustee and Rowley
although most of what she appears to do
is TV hits Miss Willis seems to want
this case to be televised eyes and I'm
sure she's very proud of herself and
finally let's talk about the lawyers who
were with Trump as he tried to overturn
the 2020 election special counsel Jack
Smith's indictment referred to six
unindicted co-conspirators all of whom
were lawyers and five of those were
actually charged along with him in
Georgia first up in this lesson after we
have a man who needs no introduction
Rudy Giuliani the former Federal
prosecutor and mayor of New York played
a central role in both Trump
impeachments in 2019 Rudy convinced
Trump that there was dirt to be had in
Ukraine on Joe Biden and the next year
he led the charge to overturn Biden's
massive Electoral College win and along
the way he leaked hair dye all over the
RNC convened a national press conference
and a landscaper's parking lot across
from a porn shop got lampooned in a
Borat movie in a highly compromising
situation earned himself several
multi-million dollar defamation suits
and got suspended from the practice of
law in the DC indictment he's described
as co-conspirator number one an attorney
who was willing to spread knowingly
false claims and pursue strategy
energies that the defendants 2020
re-election campaign attorneys would not
and in Georgia he's facing 13 charges
for his role in The Conspiracy to steal
that states electors for Donald Trump
standing next to Rudy at the RNC Podium
but leaking conspiracy theories instead
of hair dye was Sydney Powell or as the
DC indictment describes her
co-conspirator 3 an attorney whose
unfounded claims of election fraud the
defendant privately acknowledged to
others sounded crazy vowing to release
the Kraken she claimed to have evidence
of massive fraud in all the swing States
Powell and her allies filed upwards of a
dozen lawsuits seeking to overturn the
election results none of them were
successful although Powell did manage to
get herself sanctioned for filing bogus
affidavits in her Michigan Kraken case
without bothering to see if they were
true after the lawsuits failed Powell
tried to get Trump to name her special
counsel so she could seize all the
voting machines investigate the fraud
that she was certain had occurred and
like Giuliani Powell is now a defendant
in multiple defamation suits filed by
voting machine companies whom she
accused of stealing the election and she
netted herself seven charges in Fulton
County also at the RNC Podium that day
was Jenna Ellis or as she describes
herself Dr Jenna Ellis constitutional
law expert Pro tip never trust any
attorney who insists on going by doctor
Ellis started her legal career in
traffic court in Colorado where she was
fired for incompetence but won her
unemployment appeal because the hearing
officer determined that she was quote
performing the duties to the best of her
ability and I quote did the best she
could with her Education and Training to
meet the expectations of the employer
she then refashioned herself as a
constitutional law professor teaching
pre-law to undergrads at a Christian
College in Colorado and self-publishing
a book decrying the Supreme Court's
legalization of gay marriage after since
it religious advocacy groups she landed
in the former president's orbit branding
herself a member of the elite strike
force that was going to keep Trump in
the White House
they did not in fact uh keep Trump in
the White House and Alice's contribution
didn't even rate a mention in Jack Smith
DC indictment but Ellis managed to get
herself a couple of charges in Georgia
so congrats on the new profile pic and
while Rudy Sydney and Jenna were fleeing
themselves at the courts and legislators
trying to get themselves to snatch
Biden's electors a team of lawyers
behind the scenes were cooking up the
legal justification for the plot to
substitute fake collectors for the real
ones on January 6. two of those managed
to get themselves named by Jack Smith in
DC and indicted by fawny Willis in
Fulton County John Eastman AKA
co-conspirator 2 and Ken chisbro AKA
co-conspirator number five uh lent's
intellectual heft to the project each
drafting a series of memos assuring
their co-conspirators that this was all
very legal and very cool in fact cheese
bro explicitly stated that a crucial
prong of his plan was quote messaging
that presents this as a routine measure
that is necessary to ensure that in the
event the courts or state legislatures
were to later conclude that Trump
actually won the state the correct
electoral slate can be counted in
Congress in January but not a single
swing state was flipped by a court or
state legislature so by January Eastman
and cheese bro had decided on a new plan
they wanted vice president Pence to
unilaterally reject electoral votes
throwing the elections for Trump both
then privately acknowledged that the
Supreme Court was unlikely to accept
their reasoning but pressed ahead anyway
in the hopes that Pence would cave to
the Mob and toss out the votes of
millions of Americans I've Eastman made
the additional error of using his work
email for his coup plotting which is you
know just a rookie mistake and to
prevent those emails from getting out he
sued to block his former employer
Chapman University from disclosing his
Communications to the house January 6
Committee in 2021 a federal judge found
that Eastman like Evan Corcoran had
likely participated in a crime with his
client Donald Trump and so the emails
had to be turned over under the crime
fraud exception to the eternity client
privilege the lawsuit also had the
effect of publicizing Eastman's
Communications including a message sent
to vice president Pence top lawyer
during The Siege the capital in which
the lawyer encouraged but one more
relatively minor violation since the mob
had already disrupted the certification
under the Electoral account Act Eastman
was charged with nine counts in Georgia
well chisbro netted seven charges
Eastman is also facing disbarment
proceedings as is Rudy Giuliani as well
as another entrant into F tier a former
doj Environmental Lawyer Jeff Clark AKA
co-conspirator 4 a justice department
official who worked on civil matters and
who with the defendant attempted to use
the justice department to open sham
election crime investigations and
influence state legislatures with
knowingly false claims of election fraud
Clark also tried to persuade acting
Attorney General Jeffrey Rosen to send a
proof of concept letter to the swing
state legislatures encouraging them to
reconvene and steal Biden's electoral
votes based on FBI investigations of
major election fraud but those
investigations did not exist and Rosen
refused to send the letter the
confrontation resulted in an oval office
Showdown on January 3rd 2021 where the
entire senior leadership of the justice
department as well as Trump's White
House Council threatened to quit if
Trump put Clark in charge of the doj in
September of 2022 the f FBI seized
Clark's phone and now he's facing a
couple of charges in Georgia on the plus
side according to Rolling Stone he's on
a short list to be attorney general in a
second Trump White House and then last
we have Trump's in-house counsel Boris
Epstein AKA season 7 Michael Cohen AKA
Coke conspirator 6 a political
consultant who helped Implement a plan
to submit fraudulent slates of
presidential electors to obstruct the
certification proceeding allegedly
Epstein is one of Trump's closest
advisors to the consternation of his
other lawyers who complain that Trump's
political strategy consistently uh
trumps his legal strategy Epstein is
reported to have talked Trump into
several of his lunar legal filings
including suits in Florida against the
Pulitzer Prize board and New York
attorney general Leticia James he also
had his phone seized by the FBI in
September 2021 and testified to the
grand jury about the fake elector's plot
in which he coordinated giuliani's
efforts on the ground while chisbro and
Eastman worked behind the scenes this
effort has not made him popular with
Trump's lawyers who blame him for
Trump's disastrous legal strategy
particularly in the documents case and
then last but not least not even making
it on to F tier let's give an honorable
mention to Alan dershowitz the famed
Harvard law professor emeritus who
represented Trump in the first
impeachment and while dersh has not
officially represented Trump since 2020
he contributes to the cause by defending
the former president daily in right-wing
media while insisting that he's a
liberal Democrat dershowitz insists that
the sitting president cannot prosecute a
former president under the Nixon
standard which is just something that he
invented he predicts that the eegean
Carroll verdict will be overturned since
the jury only found him liable for kinda
molesting her and he confidently asserts
that the call where Trump demanded that
Georgia Secretary of State Brad
raffensberger fined 11 780 votes is
actually evidence that Trump was simply
demanding another recount uh despite the
there had been three recounts by then
and he does it without being paid a
nickel by Trump's pack just a stand-up
guy and another F tier habit of Trumps
is eating steak with ketchup but if
you'd like a delicious s-tier meal
delivered straight to your door Today's
sponsor Factor can help because Factor
makes meeting your nutrition goals
easier than ever by delivering fresh
never Frozen dietitian approved meals
right to your doorstep and the meals are
completely ready to eat so you can
eliminate the hours that it would take
to shop meal prep and cook so you can
spend your day doing the things that you
actually want to do Factor meals arrive
pre-prepared and ready to eat in just
two minutes the same amount of time that
I could put on my shoes to go to the
grocery store my Factor meal is already
done because sometimes I just want a
good healthy meal without having to cook
and it's surprisingly affordable and now
Factor offers Gourmet plus meals as part
of your weekly options which means you
can get a little gourmet with your meal
plan whenever you're craving something
special gourmet meals like surf and turf
or Surf and surf shrimp and salmon all
of factors meals are extremely delicious
like bruschetta shrimp risotto Green
Goddess chicken and grilled Steakhouse
filet mignon ready in just two minutes
their menus are updated weekly with 34
different options so you can choose your
favorite meals or like Factor craft your
order based on your taste preferences in
meal history so give factor a try by
heading to factor75.com and use the code
legal eagle 50 to get 50 off your first
Factor box or just click on the link
that's on screen right now or down in
the description and use code legal eagle
50 to get 50 off your first Factor box
so click below right now after that
click on this box over here for more
legally eagle or I'll see you in court